let's talk about the list yes oh yes
siraj tell us what is the list the list
is a power ranking of people who need
their phones taken away started
well yeah that's power ranking i mean it
started off as a power ranking
but it's a usually a top 10 of people
who need their phones taken away based
on bad tweets and i do it weekly
uh do it monday nights tonight oh it's
monday night yes so we're going to do
the top 10 yes people on twitter we are
doing a uh a
we are doing abbreviated version i
narrowed it to just 10 candidates this
week we're just going to debate the
order of which ones just because
you know
i can take up to like two hours doing
this on that i think you've got a list
here you got to get from this
starting from 10. yeah so this is the
top 10
list of the worst tweets of the week of
december 13 2021. do you do this on on
on rumble or youtube yeah i do rumble
youtube and twitch because you know top
tens are huge on youtube
like people love top 10 lists where it's
like the top 10 whatever well i have a
feeling that youtube is a bit
islamophobic
and they don't want to put my stuff up
there that explains it yeah because if
they weren't they would just put you on
the front page exactly yeah that's right
it's wrong think yeah yeah yeah that
proves it yeah yeah all right we have
the list here all right do you want to
read it yeah well so here's the thing i
usually read it in a pakistani accent
because
my
family they are from pakistan so i can
read read bloomberg they are coming in
number 10
some of the advice on how to cope
with rising inflation includes
spend your paycheck right away
sounds so wise we did and we did talk
about this one that is a very good tweet
to make the list wow
um i usually go into commentary so like
do you think this deserves recognition
ian luke absolutely they're absolutely
insane i was talking about this before i
even knew it was on the list because
it's it's a an absolute slap in the face
to anyone paying any uh attention to
reality now what if it said spend your
paycheck right away
on bitcoin that's what i'm saying that
i'd be like that's a good thing if
they're what they're saying is
spend it before it gets devalued on
something that's going to inflate in
value then okay but if it's spend it
hazardously on anything
you're gonna love number nine we should
we should get uh we should get like a
clear plastic for the tv so i can take a
sharpie and write with
bitcoin yeah all right all right number
nine the hill line
bitcoin surge a bone for white
nationalists
the funny thing is it's a boon for
everybody exactly
why is it not white national well
because look they take they they take
the umbrella of everyone and then within
the umbrella of everyone and there's a
smaller umbrella of white nationalists
and that's the one that's going to get
clicks yeah
remember that ryan i think it was ryan
long that uh was making a skit about the
employees that work at vice and they
took and they took
reproductive toys and they just started
throwing it around the board wasn't ryan
long okay but i remember if i think ryan
long did something but i think it was
someone else i don't know someone will
tell me on the internet but they took uh
a male reproductive organ toy and they
like literally threw it at a board
filled with a bunch of names and it
stuck and then they literally created
their titles out of it i think this is
this was the case of that ryan long's
was where he was like you have a bag of
nouns and two different nouns and he was
like why blank is bad for blank and he
would just pull random one ones up and
then he would like the funny thing is he
would show actual articles titled that
so yes
bitcoin search a boon for white
nationalists much in the same way that
bitcoin boone is a surge for quite
literally anyone who owns bitcoin yes
and they're pets
it's just amazing i was actually reading
a chart the other day that showed that
bitcoin is actually a huge boon for
black people and investors in every
field and al salvadorians
and has lifted a lot of people out of
poverty
yeah not racist enough
all right all right this is this is an
economics heavy list i'm usually not
used to this it's usually a lot more
unhinged but don't worry it gets worse
uh number eight we have paul krugman he
say he tweets aside from priorities is
this even true
is there any good reason to believe
that inflation hits low income
households especially hard
okay hold on hold on he's an economist
now he's obviously yeah go ahead tim no
it just reminds me of um the feature
realm episode where the judge
is um
he's judge whitey and he's like oh poor
people the only poor people i want to
hear about are the people who tend to my
pores the spa like that's that's what it
reminds me of yeah pretty much that's
accurate i mean krugman's just been
wrong on so many things
it's uh i don't even know where to start
with this one the man has no shame he
doesn't so when i love this because
when bloomberg is like quick spend your
paycheck as soon as you can because of
inflation and then he's like is that
really hitting low-income households
especially hard it's like bro they're
literally telling them to dump their
money as fast as possible like that's
pretty bad what he's saying is if money
is becoming less valuable than the
people that don't have any money aren't
being affected by it anyway
that's a good point
it's like
why are you worried about inflation you
don't care
no you don't have money so why are you
worried about the value of money
duh
it was so easy that makes sense number
seven
president biden
tweets uh
the united states basis that's when they
are due
that's why today i signed a bill to fast
track the process to raise our debt
limit and if you don't believe me you
shut the hell up your mouths yeah
this is effectively the president of the
united states saying
we're in debt so i took out a new credit
card yeah i took a new new loan a new
line of credit yeah
see the thing is you know they don't
like it they don't like ponzi schemes
but they
they they like ponzi zoo you know what i
mean like the government doesn't want
you doing it they want to do it but
that's literally what our economic
system is yeah it's the federal reserve
yeah
number six here we go lauren
365
348 children went missing in 2020 you
haven't heard a word from media about it
therein lies the problem oh i'm sorry
they're allies what the problem
i see what she did there i'm so therein
lies the problem but that's not why it's
less worth it yeah it should be i mean
this is a thing this is a this is a
thing remember remember like a month or
two ago with uh the gabby petito case
and then you had joyrie going on msnbc
saying that this is a this is a missing
white woman syndrome and
no one has talked about like missing
people of color since
it's in the same token here with lauren
bober wait you can there's nothing
stopping lauren
from talking about tweeting about
missing children she's saying the media
doesn't run these stories you know what
i mean no i know that yeah is that an
accurate number is that domestically or
internationally is that a world number
or a u.s number or is that even just a
made-up number
good question
is m lies a word no it's not no but like
my bigger question he's spitting right
there i like that
he's making up words like i do
i gotta say i gotta say
i think this should be lower on the list
i think you think it should be lower on
the list where you think where do you
think it should be i don't know i like
it's like
it's a weak point you know what i mean
you think like number 10 yeah yeah maybe
okay we can move it to number 10. yeah
maybe number 10. you know because
one of the things that really bothers me
about media criticism is they they go
like
x happened and i don't see the media
talking about it right and then there'll
be like 20 articles
yeah no it's a lazy it's lazy criticism
for sure and uh that is on my uh intern
ben who is uh ben morsi
who is going to be fired for this
ben
what have you done then you could go
follow him on twitter
oh here we go yeah yeah yeah yeah any
time i don't have time to say the next
one anytime but i'ma let you do the
honor okay i say it okay i say it
number five
the atlantic
across the united states well-meaning
citizens are raising awareness about the
child acts
trafficking pandemic epidemic that
doesn't exist
kate tiffany unpacks how an internet
conspiracy theory birth a 21st century
morphinic
now did the cnn and cia pay for this
particular piece of journalism or child
what kind of rolling elite person how
much money did they drop to to cover up
their horrible antics when it comes to
hurting children in unspeakable ways the
real epstein is in an underground bunker
bunker writing the story the real
epstein are the friends we made along
the way
but i was talking about this during the
broadcast as well uh so i'm happy that
made the list because it's really
incredulous to say the least and the
owner of the atlantic is seen in a very
weird bikini photo with galene maxwell
cuddling up to her so there's that
here's the issue
they say um
child trafficking epidemic
how do you define something when you're
when you're using a like a metaphor to
describe what it is right like i said
literally saying it's like an epidemic
of trafficking but what's the threshold
for that there's no cdc guidelines right
is there like if a hundred thousand kids
it's officially an epidemic because the
question is if we get a bunch of stories
if we know what epstein was doing if we
know what the cnn producer is accused of
doing if we hear these stories at the
cia officer and we know there are
powerful elites doing really messed up
stuff with kids at what point do you
decide it's an epidemic yo america is
oding hard on child trafficking
it is terrible account i hate this one
but let's read
january 6 was biggest crime ever
perpetuated against the united states
and nearly every republican is complicit
but that's true
every republican
are we every republican um even the
people are registered after january 6th
it's isn't it but isn't it a crazy thing
to believe that like
january 6 had a bunch of
like a bunch of bumbling people walking
through open doors where the police
opened it for him
cops were being reprimanded because they
were taking selfies with people there
was that riot in the front where they
were fighting with police and all that
stuff and it's bad of course yeah the
biggest crime didn't the british burn
down the white house yeah wasn't the
french
no the french british did in 1812 i
think uh 911 pearl harbor
oklahoma city yeah many such cases many
such cases yeah yeah
i mean quite literally any serial killer
yeah
jim crow
slavery
the tostiga experiments yeah that's one
wow
mk ultra i mean there's just this oh
yeah yeah yeah january 6 wouldn't even
make any reasonable list of questions
it wouldn't even make the top ten yeah
it won't make the top one
yeah
you know i could probably make i could
probably make a list of 100 crimes
against the united states that were
worse than january 6 very easily oh yeah
you want to make that list next time
we'll do that next time the horse crimes
against the united states ranked but
here's the funny thing it's like if you
go back through history there's going to
be like ransacking of orphanages there's
going to be like the burning down of
like government facilities there's going
to be like the bombing of a military
base how many how many military-based
bombings have happened over the past 20
years
like
in the middle east you know oh yeah
middle east for sure i mean
yeah
tons i mean
yep can't even name them off the table
you'd have to go like non-wartime
uh tragedies against united states why
it'd be too easy if you did wartime too
yeah we're just creating new lists out
of the list this is crazy sub list
well this is a very common one they just
they just yeah they say things they
don't think you know yeah number three
stuart stevens now this guy is actually
lincoln project
to be more concerned about inflation
than a plot to end democracy is pretty
much a definition of the choice made by
many and pre
dubbed out to
germany oh my god that is that uh wow
very astute stuart stevens wow uh the
insight here is is astounding um
yeah yeah you think it's you think it's
appropriate for the list yeah top three
i don't know about top three okay but i
think the midas touch one is like should
be up higher you think maybe flip them
maybe flip them okay i don't know he is
pretty unhinged there i mean
what so why why would you argue that
this is worse than the midas touch
because it's just like absolutely
like like low iq to like it's highest
degree it's
remember when you were a kid and they
would be like you know are you pt you
ever hear that one from a little kid and
then like no matter what you say it's
like a stupid joke that kid say like if
you say no they say you're not potty
trained and you say yes and say you're a
pregnant teenager like
the stupidest child like that's that's
how i view this
it's like operating under an assumption
that like
he's decided something is happening
that's really really bad yeah like what
i mean is you know like no matter how
you view it he's going to imply
the worst possible thing is currently
occurring like there's no
uh he he he's he's his statement
assumes too much i guess yeah uh so
you'd think it shouldn't be top three
though no because look at this one
january 6 was the biggest crime i ever
perpetrated i mean i i'm kind of with
you on that i don't know maybe you're
right you know you know what you know
what i'm let's think about like poker
right so let's do this uh uh midas touch
says january 6 was the biggest crime
ever perpetrated against the united
states that's kind of like an ace high
you know what i mean like it's one
statement oh no no he added every
republican is complicit that's a pair of
aces okay but here let's go down here we
have a couple things he's saying
inflation isn't as bad there's a plot to
end democracy and he's comparing it to
world war ii germany we got three of a
kind yeah yep yep so i think it does
yeah i think it does make the right spot
all right that's fine
number two
daily mail online
32 000 americans who think they'll be
alive for christmas
we'll be dead by years and years yes
experts
that's a good one number one better be
pretty damn good because that's great
that's huge right there
all that's missing is and you may be one
of them yeah yeah
thank you thank you for the christmas
present daily mail
i really appreciate it
okay here we go number one
she spells it noel but it's actually now
she did it for that christmas thing
this is after the horrible horrible
tornadoes that
over the weekend in kentucky or
like over 64 people have died
so i'm not going to read this in the
pakistani accent i'll just read this in
my normal voice
she tweets out sorry kentucky maybe if
your two senators hadn't spent decades
blocking legislation to reduce climate
change you wouldn't be suffering from
climate disasters if it's any
consolation mcconnell and rand have
effed over all of us too well i i do
gotta say she's correct because as we
know rand paul has been actively
assisting china with their pollution in
you know um and well america of course
has been wait
rand paul has no power over what china
is doing you're telling me so that's not
that's not the case
uh
yeah what what what so so um
rand paul and mitch mcconnell right have
been uh assistant they're the reasons
why the the tornadoes right yeah right
so they're in charge of the weather
machines yes right well no what you're
saying basically is that you know rand
paul has been blocking uh legislation uh
against china right right
wait wait what oh she's talking about
america yeah oh she thinks we have
control over the other oh yes yeah oh
yeah are you talking oh you're talking
about the trichlorofluoromethane that's
being emitted from from china's uh
factories in the northeastern provinces
of the country that has like the highest
ozone depletion factor yeah and also
just like the general carbon if you want
to get really simple
and so um the funny thing about this
whole climate change thing especially is
like
uh the united states passes all these
bills all these laws locally uh banning
plastic straws batting plastic bags and
yet the pacific gyre and all the garbage
is still there why because other
countries yeah so if you're concerned
about climate change and you're blaming
rand paul
you have no idea what you're talking
about yeah this this lady needs her
phone taken away immediately
scroll down if you scroll down lydia
you can see that she deleted that tweet
i mean that ratio
does she earn does she earn any kind of
credit for deleting it um
just more humiliation
i'm surprised we don't have democratic
politicians calling to defund tornadoes
uh with that same kind of logic now it's
absolutely insane to use the tragedy
that people are going through right now
for political brownie points i mean
that's just disgusting you know i i miss
the good old days when the public
warning was don't fire your gun at a
tornado to stop this [ __ ]
wasn't
what didn't donald trump talk about like
nuking like didn't he yeah he wanted to
nuke a hurricane he did once yeah well
he asked about i don't think he wanted
he was like if we nuke it will it do
anything in there like trump like the
hurricane
it's as big as new york
it's like nothing's gonna happen he
watched too much sharknados baller move
now i gotta say something i gotta say
something
i really i understand why you made nell
number one
because it combined like bad taste with
disrespect
bad timing and just
political like exploitation
and it was a very serious you know
i want the daily mail one to be the
first because it it's these are good you
know i'm looking at all these things and
i kind of view it like like poker you
know what i mean like
so this this 32 000 americans who think
they'll be alive for christmas will be
dead and they did dead in all caps i
love that that's that's that's the right
method right by years and expert
warrants it just combines so much it's
like almost a royal flush of bad tweet
you know what i mean yeah but
i feel like
when weighed against a sensitive and
devastating event like nels cavall's
that trumps
that so let's break this one down you've
got the kentucky tragedy yep you've got
political exploitation
you've got climate change you've got a
dig at mitch mcconnell and and uh and
rand paul
and
she's including herself as a victim in
the uh uh yeah and also
and also in the beginning and also in
the beginning she starts off with sorry
kentucky it's very blase as if like
it's like you know like you know sorry
this all happened to you but
it's like a royal flush yeah i think it
hits it i think it is
that is easily number one with a bullet
it's like someone that you then fire
into a tornado
this is the equivalent of like someone
in real life getting run over by a car
and then like a liberal lady walking
over be like it's all fossil fuel's
fault
called ambulance help and like nope
sorry
we got to burn more fossil fuels and get
that ambulance
there was that story where a guy working
in an amazon warehouse i guess texted
they're not letting us leave
terrible i just got to say ladies and
gentlemen i don't you know whoever
whoever you work for if there's a
tornado coming
think about yourself first protect your
family if your boss is like you can't
leave yo tell your boss have a nice day
because i can go talk to the labor
department you know the labor board
after the tornado and we can deal with
this and you trying to you know play
some be some bs man thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you